you embarrassed me in front of her you
embarrassed me in front of her I was
looking for it what happen here I do the
better D'Onofrio sis's you know he's
been quoting that for a couple ways so
now I fucking know what that is I
haven't been the only one people would
come up and whatever daredevil get
brought up half the time I would just
hear somebody say you embarrassed me in
front of her if you even mention the
word ain't been what Wilson Fisk boy
talk about a totally different kingpin
then what you know okay so I know I know
the kingpin in the comic I know he's the
kingpin come come I can't remember not
in the Lord necessarily like skin killer
but certainly in the way he act it was a
little more like the movie this one is a
little bit more fascinating because
either they're introducing him in a way
you would not normally introduce a
character like this which I like when
they do that it's like Keyser söze for
ham from the first three episodes like
no one sees him no one named it's like
kind of awkward and shy on dates and
stuff like that like and you know you
see him smash your guy's head is okay
always kind of a thug - and the fine
thing is that I'm interested to see
where it goes from here because this is
an interesting trick I see mostly movies
but some shows do where their
introduction of a character is not
necessarily what you're gonna see the
majority of the time which sometimes
throws me off a bit but at the same time
it's enjoyable to go back and re-watch
it again because it's not necessarily
this isn't who the character isn't
either it's that we're showing you an
aspect that you wouldn't be familiar
with it's it catches you off-guard
which I like because I'm sure we're
gonna see him as the crime boss and he
knows what he's doing and he can be a
little nuts and easy you know that's
you're very strong what he will not well
no but I mean like just took a guy's
head off in a car door no we had to get
where he is yeah oh yes there has to be
this strength in this kind of
for me he is one of probably the
scariest villains I've seen in a TV show
in a long time or even a movie because
he gives off this I can't describe a lot
of people will say it's uh he's acting
kind of autistic or on the spectrum and
then maybe the means with which Dena
Theo is trying to kind of tap into the
character but I feel like there's
something a little more going on
underneath there it in the pauses it's
not to me just like oh he's acting like
somebody with autism it's it's almost
like an every pause there's a suppressed
rage like he just will pause and think
and like you kind of wonder what's going
on there in that pause it's almost like
he's suppressing something and like it's
nerve wracking from the beginning that
there's something just kind of off about
whatever is going on in that head
whatever you know if he kind of pauses
and then that scene comes out of nowhere
at the end of this episode and it's so
brilliant because pretty much from this
point on at least for me seeing and
having seen it already
I'm just freaking terrified of this guy
like the reppin because you never know
at what point he's gonna snap like that
again
why Mike it was just such and over
something so what appears kind of to
most people a little bit more on the
meaningless side like starting a whole
mafia war which it seems clear that this
may have been kind of an endgame for him
eventually anyway
but to just lose it like that and to
just like take a guy's head off with a
card or like crazy
ya know I think that's what well that's
what makes it such an interesting
introduction because like I said the the
kingpin I think we both kind of know
that that we see you know and spider-man
and
and stuff I mean he is I don't know how
do I describe a lot like in the cartoon
he was voiced by Oh
Frollo what's his name frigging his name
Tony Jay yeah Tony Jay boys too man it
was kind of the Tony Jay persona except
he was also very very strong you know he
was large but he was also very strong to
who's calculating and thinking and stuff
like that he's what you would think of
when you hear the word kingpin he's like
The Godfather he's all this stuff but
mr. Monday introduced him in a totally
different light that you wouldn't expect
and I think you're probably right now
I'll admit now I'm looking forward to
the strategy and the planning I'm
looking forward to seeing that because I
didn't get any of that in this episode
but that's part what makes it so
interesting is now knowing this knowing
that he can snap over something like
this he'll be more interesting to walk
it's scary and the thing is it works in
two levels because you feel like there
was almost a build-up to it because he's
always been talking strangely and he has
this particularly when he looks at
Vanessa he has this intense look you
know at the dinner table scene she's
kind of looking away or she fiddles with
their hair a little he whenever he talks
her he's always just I I would see him
look down I mean I feel like whenever he
had something important to say
like he would like click on and then you
get this stare well I got the way you
put was but the suppressed repressed
rage is definitely out of there like
waiting to come out and you can make you
try it finally comes up so you're kind
of waiting for it and now that you know
that it's there and that it can turn on
and off in an instant like it kind of
cut it colors everything from here on
out because any normal senior in if
anybody's crossing him or something
you're gonna be sitting there going is
this gonna be the next time he snaps you
just you just never know and you know
he's capable of doing this on a deep
personal level just to somebody like
he's been hiring goons to do his dirty
work but now we know you'll just take
your head off himself well there's some
when I think that's what makes it so
interesting that you have not only
what's that whole restaurant I mean
everybody in there got up I mean like
everybody kind of space so it's not only
see that powerful he can he has people
where he could pay them all he's that
uncomfortable that he had they do that
uncomfortable they has to do it but also
that in most movies or shows where they
do something like this where the big bad
guy kills someone
it's a thug it's a henchman maybe kind
of a big name thanks Aaron
pretty early on I think really from
episode 1 that this these are kid the
brothers are two huge names and by doing
this and killing this guy and pretty
much starting this war again you're kind
of saying here so well okay they don't
usually do that so early they usually
let it build up a little bit so to start
off like that's like okay well where's
it gonna go friend well not only is it
like a lot of times over there thug
their henchmen but man when he like just
is done there and like I look I love
Wesley sitting in the car just staring
just you know the guys look good and
he's like hmm it just gets out and he's
like whatever like you know the two of
them together I'm just like what a
couple of psychopaths and it's not just
a he's a thug it's that the way he walks
and carries himself it's the strange
dichotomy if he is so uncomfortable
sometimes in his own skin but he also
walks he's almost like a gorilla like he
just struts with this animal-like stride
that he's like a monster like it's it's
almost like a movie monster or something
beyond just like oh the kingpins a
common thug or oh he's just a criminal
who's just above it all won't get his
hands dirty Heath he is just one of the
scariest motherfuckers I've seen if you
told me this guy like if you didn't tell
me this guy let it a big crime like he
was the number one guy the leader of a
crime ring and stuff like that I would
probably think more about this guy kinda
like watching an reporter of a serial
killer like we're studying a killer a
psychopath but not necessarily a crime
boss and that's why I'm so interested in
seeing the rest of it because they have
build them up this is his introduction
and now it's like well okay so now I got
that side that it's usually their way
around they show the business side and
the professional side and now why he's
at the top and the
you know the point where they break or
they go sloppy or nuts or whatever it's
like whatever half a season in if even
that maybe even more so it's interesting
we spoke to the Rao and personal story
first yeah it came on a day-to it's him
looking at the exact concealing some of
you with the business stuff yeah all
handled on the side by Wesley you see
there's very little bit as a
conversation or two between Fisk and
Wesley just one in the car and it's very
quick yeah very short you barely see it
and what's often is get works cuz you
now get a feeling for him as a character
which then informs his business dealings
and like we've learned a couple of
important things one obsession with
control he had full control over the
restaurant losing control made him go
nuts
appearing embarrassed made him go yeah
definitely had a self-image thing and
that control spills over into what he's
doing because he was talking about how
he wants to like remake this
neighborhood and everything and and he's
like well you can grow up here and so it
seems to be control and manipulation is
gonna be a big part of this and he's
controlling all the other families and
wants to start a war and so this is the
beginning of a theme I think with him
but yeah you know it's one of those I
think when there's a weird comparison
when I saw a Fish Called Wanda and you
see Kevin Kline with Michael Palin the
second Michael Palin starts stuttering
he just gets this look like oh wow I'm
gonna have to put up with that and most
movies would wait until about the
halfway point for him to start to get
annoyed but he immediately gets annoyed
starts making fun of him starts mocking
him and just immediately attacks this
guy you know just for a stuttering being
so cruel where most movies would wait
along you know like the halfway point do
it and again I think I like a show or a
movie that'll just be like nope you know
what's coming so we're going to jump to
it and we're gonna add a little extra
now we'll give you sort of this stuff
you thought was coming you know but
we're gonna sort of switch it around and
now you've got these really
uncomfortable watching it because it's
like okay this stuff I know but man oh
man that shit you opened up with and
that's gonna be going around my head
when I'm watching this guy I'm sure do
is you know his business
dealings you know and also start a war
it looks like so yeah no I he really
looks the part he he even sounds the
part I like that he's wearing black
instead of white
I honestly find it a hell of a lot
scarier and I like it I like his
portrayal it's different than the Ving
Rhames who i Ving Rhames of other things
in the movie that i actually really do
know i Ving Rhames to me is a little
more this could through different
kingpins the earlier kingpin was a
little goofier and that strikes me as
the more Ving Rhames kind of king you
know the big schemes and this and that
the the later kingpin was a little not
quite like this but closer to this a
little more down-to-earth not big into
like giant death traps and goofy sort of
schemes but way more into this sort of
criminal empire running that you see
here and so yeah it it works scary um
the rest of it is good it's pretty dry
they abduct Clare in order to get a name
and then daredevil kicks some ass
which I really like again it it's kind
of like the Batman I kind of want where
it's like it was all attacked in the
dark
yeah no I was gonna say that voice they
obviously had a little bit of bass to
train up to it uh but I think that's a
good example of how you can do a Batman
voice and not have to have it really
good I'll just talk about Christian Bale
I mean a lot of people when they try to
do abandon boys they tried to make good
time mysterious and the only one who
didn't really is Conroy who maybe you
know this voice Rosie you know and this
way they're very articulate and very
strong you know but also just enough to
be intimidating there's this confidence
- I am a fuckin badass but you know I am
also in the shadow this is a very
matter-of-fact just like put the gun
down now or you're never gonna use that
freakin hand again like I'm walking out
here
[Music]
but it's just this voice you hear from
the court is that again like I it's so
funny like that the flash is the Marvel
show I always wanted then daredevil is
the DC kind of thing it's funny how this
is working out but I I like it I like
that they're both thinking out of the
box or really I kind of like a more
interest in the TV work now yeah well
the TV is amazing right now I knew we
said this yeah but it's really exploding
we're kind of a new golden age right now
and yes because it shows like this and
and characters like these immediate zero
these are all really great care to that
fan you know even like it was a dose and
uh you know she's uh really she says
she's support you know she's every
supportive character you've seen in
millionaire superhero movies but you
know if I guy every time she's taught
and she says you know feel my heart you
know it's beating in fact because I am
afraid I've never been more afraid I
like but we all are and you can do say
it's like I'm really listening to her
and I'm totally on board with her and I
think it's you know it's decent writing
but it's like it really is the
performance these are good good
performers in this show
they're good solid performances I think
the other thing between Fisk taking out
the Russian and Karen page getting
attacked in episode 1 and now rosario
Dawson there is like a sense of anyone's
a target which I think makes it even
scarier we're talking about why do you
feel so isolated alone watching the show
it's almost like shows about a
government conspiracy or something where
everything is stacked against you and
there's nothing you can do because they
know everything about you they can do
whatever they want
you know everything operates in the
shadows and yeah I feel like just every
single person's a target like anybody
Murdock runs into including his own band
self what and here's a lot of thing I'll
say because but when they have um okay
you always hear you're being watched
they're spies everywhere you hear that
every show every movie uh in this one
you feel it because a it doesn't open up
with people watching or people looking
behind the corner or something like that
it's just a person over there he's a guy
that woman over there she's also with
them and stuff like that
you know and they lucky you never see
them turn right you never see them do
anything and that the restaurant that
whole time all those people were in on
it it's like well I didn't know that
it's this wonderful sense of you
legitimately do not know going into a
scene who's watching you and now you're
starting to become comfortable with the
fact that you are always being one it's
what ninja should be yeah like now guys
in black outfits throwing you know
Chinese stars or whatever even though
the Japanese but it's you know plain
clothed sort of people like your best
friend could be totally on the take and
stab you in the back like it could be
anybody like he's bought the
neighborhood pretty much but perhaps the
whole city though that this really is
dark disturbing uncomfortable and
comic-book done right and there's no
there's no major heroes I love that line
I had forgotten about that line where
it's just like oh well you know I would
understand if it was some God with a
hammer or some guy in an iron suits you
know but this is some guy with a black
mask I think it really hammers in part
of them yeah yeah hammers in the fact
that this is all bottom of the barrel
grassroots criminal like this is too
shadowy and off off the radar or under
the radar for your major superheroes
they're off battling aliens yeah doing
whatever they're doing in the age of
Ultron or you know like so really who's
left like this is really the garbage
collecting of you know superhero stuff
going on but it's beyond important and
that's why these criminals are getting
away with it because they're just so
under the radar and that's so not
seemingly important well I think we've
both been getting a lot of flack for
people saying like people accusing us
say you know we're angry that you can't
make a dark you know superhero movie or
show or whatever oh yeah and it's like
no no you can but it has to be smart it
has to be different it has to be
challenging
it can't be everything that we see a
million times they can't be you know
it's so plain then explanatory it has to
have a combination of everything and the
show really does it's the best part the
best part of
this show some of the best parts are
like The Dark Knight which is a City
story and I like that aspect of it and
add for people just like oh you're good
the Dark Knight's one of my favorite I
love Batman Begins I love Tim Burton's
Batman you know I didn't like me in the
steel because I think it was anywhere
near dark enough we're gonna go dark go
all out dark but don't half-ass it um
but that's neither here nor there no I
love dark things yeah um since it's a
city and that's - yeah yeah I like I
like Sin City too
you know I and ironically this is Marvel
giving us dark and ironically I really
like the flash and I consider that
lighter and that's DC giving us that so
it's or not I'm not skewing towards one
or the other here ya know it should just
do it right do it intelligent and try
something new balance it out you know
and I think that's what they're doing I
think it's it's definitely showing cuz
it's a big hit and people want to see
more of it and we will see more of it
next time yeah that thing you embarrass
me